die explodierenden Gaspreise haben
Folgen für uns alle deshalb erklären wir
wie sich der Gaspreis normalerweise
zusammensetzt warum der Gaspreis so
stark gestiegen ist und welche neuen
staatlichen Maßnahmen helfen sollen
der Gaspreis in Deutschland besteht in
der Regel aus einem Grund- und einem
Arbeitspreis der Grundpreis deckt die
Fixkosten der Gaslieferanten ab und ist
unabhängig vom tatsächlichen Verbrauch
er macht nur einen kleinen Teil des
Gesamtpreises aus durchschnittlich
beträgt der rund 120 Euro pro Jahr
ausschlaggebend ist der Arbeitspreis
über ihnen wird der tatsächliche
Verbrauch pro Kilowattstunde abgerechnet
er setzt sich aus drei großen
Teilbereichen zusammen
[Musik]
erstens aus den Kosten für den Transport
über das Gasnetz die sogenannten
Netzentgelte sie sind staatlich
reguliert wie viel Geld die privaten
Netzbetreiber maximal verlangen dürfen
bestimmt die Bundesnetzagentur
zweitens aus den Kosten durch Steuern
und Abgaben an Start und Kommunen hier
macht die Mehrwertsteuer normalerweise
den mit Abstand größten Teil aus ab
Oktober wird sie zumindest zeitweise
gesenkt
daneben müssen auch Öko-Steuern wieder
CO2-Preis bezahlt werden sie sollen die
Umstellung auf umweltfreundliche
Energien vorantreiben
die größten Auswirkungen auf den
Gaspreis haben jedoch drittens die
Kosten für den Einkauf und die
Lieferungen des Erdgases denn beides
erfolgt im freien Wettbewerb das heißt
die Gasanbieter können hierbei hohe
Gewinne einfahren je nachdem wie günstig
die Erdgas bekommen und wie teuer sie es
weiterverkaufen und wie viel Geld sie
für Personalverwaltung etc ausgeben für
Industrie und Gewerbe gelten in der
Regel wesentlich günstigere Preise als
für Privatkunden das hängt zum einen mit
dem viel höheren Verbrauch zusammen ein
Mengenrabatt sozusagen und zum anderen
mit Vergünstigungen bei den Steuern und
Netzentgelten
die meisten Energieunternehmen berechnen
lange im Voraus wann Sie welche
Gasmengen brauchen den Großteil davon
kaufen Sie normalerweise langfristig ein
am sogenannten Terminmarkt dadurch
können sie das Risiko plötzlicher
Preissprünge klein halten es könnten
aber auch direkte bilaterale Verträge
mit den Förderunternehmen geschlossen
werden
beispielsweise gab es mit dem russischen
Unternehmen Gazprom Lieferverträge über
mehr als 20 Jahre doch an die hält sich
Russland nun nicht mehr ist der
Verbrauch vor allem im Winter besonders
hoch oder fallen Lieferungen aus muss
zusätzlich Gas eingekauft werden das
passiert kurzfristig am Spot-Markt die
Einkaufspreise bestimmt dabei wie in der
freien Wirtschaft üblich allein der
Markt im Vergleich zu 2021 ist der Preis
2022 für Erdgas an den Börsen
zwischenzeitlich um fast tausend Prozent
gestiegen ein noch nie dagewesener
Zentrum
schon Ende 2021 ließ eine gestiegene
Nachfrage den Gaspreis deutlich in die
Höhe schießen nach den zwei
pandemie-jahren hat die Weltwirtschaft
großen Energiehunger vor allem in Asien
neu hinzu kam in Deutschland die CO2
Steuer auf fossile Brennstoffe wie Öl
und Gas und die heimischen Gasspeicher
waren noch Lehrer als sonst sie mussten
wieder aufgefüllt werden
trotzdem wurde Erdgas auch weiterhin zur
Stromgewinnung benötigt und genutzt
dann die große Unsicherheit ums
russische Gas die neu gebaute Pipeline
nordstream 2 war zunächst nur umstritten
wegen des russischen Angriffskrieges
stoppte Deutschland das Projekt durch
die anderen Pipelines kam erst weniger
dann zum Teil gar kein Gas mehr aus
Russland Ende September die Meldungen
dass an den nordstream Röhren mehrere
gasflex entstanden sind wohldurch
Sabotage Fachleute und auch Politiker
waren weiter vor möglichen Engpässen und
explodierenden Gaspreisen so treibt die
Stimmungslage im Land die Preise
zusätzlich hoch doch auch in einer
solchen Situation gibt es Gewinner mit
Unsicherheit und großer Nachfrage lassen
sich besonders gut Geschäfte machen an
den Börsen haben Spekulanten leichtes
Spiel
zumal auch die Sorge besteht ob im
Norden die neuen Terminals für
Flüssiggas bald wirklich startbereit
sind und dann verlässlich große Mengen
LNG liefern
[Musik]
um die Belastung durch die gestiegenen
Energiepreise abzufedern wird ab Oktober
für anderthalb Jahre die Mehrwertsteuer
auf den Gasverbrauch reduziert von
bisher 19 auf 7%
. zudem hat sich die EU auf eine
Solidaritätsabgabe von Gas Kohle und
Ölkonzernen geeinigt die
Energieunternehmen müssen also einen
Teil ihrer übermäßigen Gewinne an den
Start abgeben mit den Einnahmen sollen
dann belastete Haushalte und Firmen in
der Energiekrise unterstützt werden
andere Länder wie Frankreich Spanien und
Kroatien haben bereits Obergrenzen für
Energiepreise eingeführt sie schützen
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher vor zu
hohen Kosten in Deutschland soll die
sogenannte gaspreisbremse indirekt auch
zum gehasst sparen animieren für eine
Grundmenge an Erdgas wird der Preis für
private Haushalte und Unternehmen
gedeckelt finanziert durch den Staat wer
darüber hinaus Energie verbraucht muss
dafür allerdings die höheren Marktpreise
zahlen die Maßnahme ist erst einmal
befristet bis 2024
eine Verlängerung ist aber jederzeit
möglich